what is it you longed for did you see me  as I am he's asked for you Mary  you need to make many sons I need you  decide decide  I can't marry a friend I'm not made for  that life then what are you made for  who is that  rejoice Jesus of Nazareth is amongst you  you must be born anew like children may  be lost and lost here will you join us  though they judge you persecute you must  forgive them  the world will only change as we change  it is up to us  we want the people to rally to rise up  that is where it begins  he spoke of peace why shouldn't she  follow him she will divide our community  you love my son don't you  then you must prepare yourself hard to  lose him  kingdom can be built through conflict  it's here within us  [Music]  this life slipping away you're here now  here isn't it  the world will only change as we change  I will not be silent  you